[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour ce bâtiment c'est une partie du
Parlement européen ici à Bruxelles qui à
cause de sa forme est appelé communément
le caprice des dieux les dieux qui nous
envoient un beau soleil et bien
justement cette semaine on parle du
bonheur en Europe reportage au Danemark
tout de suite le tour de l'actualité
européenne avec la crise en Grèce qui
s'agrave
le temps presse en Grèce le pays doit
rembourser une partie de sa gigantesque
dette avant le 19 mai il compte sur les
49 milliards d'aides promis par ses
partenaires et par le Fond Monétaire
International en échange le Premier
ministre George papendreéo assure
qu'athen fera de nouveaux efforts pour
réduire ses déficits message bien reçu à
Berlin où Angela Merkel a légèrement
adouci sa
position je le dis très clairement
l'Allemagne va aider la Grèce si les
conditions sont
remplies triomphe électoral pour Heines
Fischer le président social-démocrate
sortant a été réélu avec près de 79 %
des voix une victoire avant tout
synonyme de Salan revers pour l'extrême
droite qui a recueilli 15,6 % des
suffrages un second mandat de 6 ans pour
Hees Fisher 71 ans une fonction
largement honorifique
éc en Pologne Yaroslav katinsk reprend
le flambeau de son frère décédé dans
l'accident de Smolensk le 10 avril il
est officiellement candidat à la
présidentielle anticipée qui aura lieu
le 20 juin prochain le chef de
l'opposition conservatrice affrontera
notamment Bronislav komorovski actuel
président par intérim candidat du Parti
libéral est favori selon tous les
sondages
et puis en Grande-Bretagne la campagne
pour les législatives touche à sa fin
les travaillistes de Gordon Brown sont
en difficulté selon les derniers
sondages face au conservateurs de David
Cameron mais l'invité surprise c'est lui
Nick 43 ans chef de fil des
libérauxdémocrates et europil polyglot
sont partis pourrait jouer les arbitres
le 6 mai
prochain et nous voici au cœur du
Parlement européen avec notre invité
Marc Tarabella bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen socialiste vous êtes
belge quand on voit ce qui est en train
de se passer actuellement sur la Grèce
et la contagion d'ailleurs qui est en
train de se produire autour du Portugal
et de l'Espagne est-ce que vous pensez
que l'Europe a raté une occasion d'agir
mais elle a peut-être pas encore raté
l'occasion d'agir mais de fait on attend
plus l'Europe active sur ces dossiers je
ne trouve pas normal que la Grèce qui
est en difficulté aujourd'hui doit payer
9 % pour emprunter alors que des pays
plus riches l'emprunte à 3 % donc il y a
une injustice flagrante il faut que la
puissance publique européenne permettent
à la Grèce d'emprunter pour s'en sortir
mais à des taux normaux et là on voit
toute parfois l'impuissance peut-être
que nous avons par rapport au au marché
financiers et ça je le déplore
profondément c'est scandale com comment
parce que le constat de tout le monde le
fait par exle domin troskan le le patron
du FMI a dit qu'il fallait agir vite
parce que sinon ça allait être
catastrophique enfin c'est le ce qu'il a
dit en tout cas dans le fond pourquoi
pourquoi l'Europe a-t-elle autant traîné
et pourquoi traîn-t-elle temps autant
maintenant il y a eu tout d'abord
évidemment les hésitations allemandes je
me réjouis que la position de Madame
Merkel soit soit assouplie mais il doit
en tout temps y avoir une solidarité
européenne al c'est vrai qu'on peut
culpabiliser le gouvernement grec
précédent parce que monsieur Papa
andreéou est arrivé il y a seulement 6
mois d'avoir fait dériver leurs finances
publiques donc c'est clair mais les
regrets sont stériles maintenant il faut
agir il y a la Grèce peut-être demain le
Portugal peut-être l'Espagne et pourquoi
pas d'autres pays la Belgique peut-être
mais la Belgique avait fait un grand
effort on avait 130 % de dett par
rapport au produit intérieur brut il y a
20 ans on a fait un effort on est arrivé
à 85 et à cause de la crise financière
et de cette bulle spéculative on a dû
intervenir et faire réaugmenter notre
dette vous êtes à 100 % à peu près c'est
ça je crois on arrive pratiquement à 100
% mais ça il faut quand même bien mettre
les responsabilités là où elles sont
c'est parce qu'il a fallu intervenir
pour soutenir le je dirais les banques
et donc soutenir l'économie à cause
d'une dérive qui vient d'une bulle
spéculative aujourd'hui les mêmes
recommencent et on spécule sur la Grèce
c'est inacceptable est-ce que est-ce que
la la crise belge on va y revenir tout à
l'heure mais est-ce que la crise la
crise politique belge qu'on vit
aujourd'hui vous pensez que ça peut
mener à une crise économique avec
justement des taux d'intérêts qui
pourrai augmenter beaucoup pour la pour
la Belgique je ne le crois pas la crise
est évidemment pas quelque chose de
réjouissant surtout à à l'aube de
présider la l'Union européenne pendant 6
mois c'est certainement pas une bonne
chose on va peu être comme un navire qui
prend la mer avec le capitaine qui a le
mal de mer donc ça c'est clair ça va
être une présidence certainement
affaiblie à mon sens parce qu'on se
précipite normalement vers vers des
élections en juin ce qui n'est pas de de
bon augure et donc clairement de fait on
aurait pu éviter cela la responsabilité
est clairement dans le chef des libéraux
flamand on on va y revenir juste juste
pour terminer sur cet aspect de la la
crise économique en Grèce qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de l'attitude de Madame
Merkel depuis le début de cette affaire
je pense qu'il aurait dû avoir plus de
solidarité dès le départ et de dire on
stoppe cela on on prend les mesures
qu'il faut on est solidaire évidemment
et on endigue
le problème qui évidemment maintenant
est récurrent et de plus en plus
important et on permet à la Grèce
d'emprunter bien sûr mais à un taux qui
est normal et pas un taux usuraire
est-ce que le Parlement européen qu'on a
pas beaucoup entendu d'ailleurs dans
cette dans cette affaire est-ce que le
Parlement européen a pas moyen de mettre
la pression sur les chefs d'État B je
crois qu'on peut ici dans ce cadre là
voter toutes les résolutions qu'on veut
à un moment donné je crois que c'est le
conseil qui doit aussi autant que le
Parlement européen avoir le sens de
l'intérêt général et pas se recroquevill
sur les intérêts nationaux pour pour
essayer de décider au niveau européen
c'est c'est tout le thème de la
gouvernance européenne la gouvernance
économique qui à mon sens on doit
l'appeler de de nos vœux pour le futur
parce qu'il faut essayer d'endiguer la
crise qui se profile maintenant au
niveau financier en Grèce et peutre dans
d'autres pays sinon ça peut être mettre
vraiment l'Union européenne en
difficulté alors un autre sujet qu'on
qu'on a dont on a parlé dans dans le
dans le reportage dans ce dans ce tour
d'Europe ce sont les élections en
Autriche on était on était inquiet je
dirais de du score que pouvait réaliser
l'extrême droite c'est c'est un
phénomène qui est européen puisquon sait
que par exemple aux Pays-Bas il va y
avoir des élections en juin l'extrême
droite peut des Pays-Bas pourut réaliser
un très bon score est-ce que la montée
des extrêmes droites en en Europe c'est
quelque chose qui vous inquiète ça
m'inquiète beaucoup même si en Autriche
ils ont fait 15 % j'estime que c'est 15
% de trop mais ça me réjouit que le
président ait quand même eu une
éclatante victoire il faut quand même le
souligner mais ça est là que ce soit
dans l'Europe ex-europe occidentale ou
dans l'Europe centrale le la Hongrie par
exemple avec le Jobic un parti qui vient
de faire plus de pratiquement 50 sièges
au Parlement hongrois ça me ça
m'interpelle beaucoup parce que c'est
évidemment l'Europe a été construite
pour tourner le dos à ces extrémismes et
et aux solutions simplistes et au
populisme divers qui conduisent à à ce
que sont on se déteste les uns les
autres donc c'est contraire à l'esprit
européen et ça m'inquiète fortement oui
alors les extrémismes c'est quelque
chose que vous connaissez bien ici je
dirais malheureusement en Belgique avec
la la crise linguistique qui est axé
autour de de trois lettres BHV ça veut
dire Bruxelles à vilev c'est un dossier
extrêmement compliqué auquel les Belges
eux-mêmes il faut bienavouer ne
comprennent pas grand-chose je vous
propose d'essayer d'éclaircir tout ça
[Musique]
regardez au cœur de la crise belge trois
lettres BHV comme Bruxelles à villevord
cet arrondissement électoral et
judiciaire est un petit coin de
francophonie dans la banlieue de
Bruxelles au sein d'une région flamande
dans un royaume coupé par une frontière
linguistique le BHV jouit d'un statut
particulier les francophones installés
en territoire flamand ont des droits ils
peuvent voter pour les partis
francophones et bénéficier de procédures
dans leur langue devant les
tribunaux des droits supplémentaires
leur sont accordés dans 6 des 35
communes flamandes de l'arrondissement
où les francophones sont majoritaires et
fortement représentés problème les
Flamands voient ses privilèges comme une
atteinte à leur intégrité territoriale
une majorité d'entre eux demande de les
limiter aussi commune a facilité en
voulant à terme ceinder l'arrondissement
de BHV en de pour rétablir l'unité
linguistique un scénario que les
francophones refusent faute de garanties
suffisantes sur leurs droits cette
querelle linguistique a donc déjà coûté
la tête du premier ministre Ive le terme
une situation inconfortable pour la
Belgique qui doit prendre la présidence
de l'Union européenne le 1er juillet
prochain alors Marc Tarabella vous êtes
député européen belge on l' dit dit vous
avez également été ministre hein
ministre fédéral belge est-ce que vous
pensez que cette situation en Belgique
pourrait aboutir à une sission du pays
d'abord laissez-moi vous féliciter pour
la votre carte elle est plus précise et
plus juste que celle de TF1 euh mais
au-delà de ça effectivement les il y a
des tensions qui sont exacerbées ça ne
date pas d'hier ce problème est
récurrent depuis longtemps et on devrait
pouvoir le résoudre par les élections
ben malheureusement le c'est ce qu' a
voulu c'est ce qu'on voulu vraement les
les libéraux flamands je pense qu'il y
avait une tout autre solution je pense
que les élections c'est pas bon pour le
moment parce que les citoyens sont
préoccupés par bien d'autres choses des
problèmes socio-économiques et beaucoup
de de collègues politiques s'occupent de
l'économie du social tous les jours et
faire les élections maintenant n'est pas
une bonne chose je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs si ce sera plus facile après
les élections qu'avant mais l'idée d'une
cission l'idée d'une partition c'est
quelque chose qui est probable je pense
que toute la Flandre le veut et la minor
la flre toute la Flandre veut cette
sission on dit 40 % à peu près dans les
sondages c'est 40 % à peu près mais vous
pensez que c'est plus non la Sion de
l'arrondissement de Bruxelles tous les
tous les la S de l'arrondissement tout
le monde la veut pas la S du pays
bienent 40 % des flamanss effectivement
il y a une une augmentation de la
proportion des gens qui veulent euh la
Sion du pays parce qu'on narrive pas à
solutionner sans doute ce problème je
crois qu'il conviendrait de le faire par
la négociation la Belgique existe depuis
maintenant 1830 et a toujours réglé les
problèmes par la voie du compromis entre
le Nord et le Sud du pays entre tous les
clivages et on est certainement
aujourd'hui en train de ternir notre
image faiseur de compromis c'est ce que
vous dites à à vos collègues députés
européens qui j'imagine doivent venir
vous voir venir vous voir dire mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ton pays oui
et c'est BHV vous l'avez très bien
expliqué c'est une gagure d'expliquer
cela même chez nous en Belgique moi
j'habite dans la région de Liège on ne
comprend pas ce que c'est BHV clairement
et donc c'est très difficile d'expliquer
n'empêche que ce problème empoisonne la
vie il faut le régler j'espère par la
négociation et puis enfin on pourra
s'occuper des tâches dont s'occupe déjà
pas mal de collègues au niveau
économique social c'est ce qui intéresse
les gens et BHV nuit à tout le monde
très bien merci beaucoup Marc Tarabella
on va parler maintenant du vivre
ensemble alors évidemment ça concerne
bien sûr la Belgique mais là on va
partir au Danemarc dans quelques
instants parce que katiya Gilder et ses
invités vont nous parler du bonheur oui
certains peuples en Europe semblent plus
heureux que d'autres c'est le cas du
Danemark supposé royaume de la béatitude
éternelle c'est le résultat d'une étude
très sérieuse mené par des
universitaires de leester en
Grande-Bretagne qui se sont fondés sur
des critères précis sécurité de l'emploi
garantie de protection sociale ou encore
bon niveau d'infrastructure alors est-ce
que c'est une image de carte postale ou
bien une réalité pour le savoir nous
sommes allés sur place à Copenhague
reportage de Thomas
[Musique]
soulier ils sont heureux très heureux et
même les plus heureux du monde le
Danemark le pays où il fait bon vivre la
qualité de vie est une priorité et fait
aujourd'hui figure d'exemple à travers
toute
[Musique]
l'Europe et ce bonheur Danois se vit à
tous les âges la preuve avec cette
famille de Copenhague dans la famille
priva voici le père chef
d'entreprise la mère une prêtre
protestante et le fils un jeune
collégien de 12 ans
8h comme tous les matins marque en
fourche en vélo direct s l'école et au
Danemark tout est pensé et aménagé pour
les cyclistes alors même C 8 km de
trajet ne lui font pas
[Musique]
peur je suis un petit peu fatigué là
j'ai besoin d'air
là à l'école danoise les règles sont
simples tout est permis ou presque les
enfants sont quasiment livrés à eux-mêm
et le travail se fait toujours en groupe
objectif les responsabilisé dès le plus
jeune
âge ici on essaie de leur parler comme
des adultes des GAL en fait quand on
discute ensemble on n'est pas dans une
relation prof élève la preuve avec ses
cours de bricolage ils ont tous une
douzaine d'années ils perent si
découpent et ce sans aucune protection
de quoi amuser les élèves St tout fois
inquiéter leur
professeurs on s'amuse beaucoup à
l'école ça nous apprend vraiment à être
créatif bien sû que c'est dangereux il y
a beaucoup de machines beaucoup d'outils
ils peuvent se blesser mais bon chaque
année avant de commencer je leur
explique comment les outils fonctionne
et les mesures de précaution à
prendre 14h fin de journée pour Mar et
ses
camarades l'après-midi est réservé au
sport
la musique un As majeur du bonheur
danois et ce n'est pas le
seul direction la band nord de
Copenhague cela fait 30 ans que le père
de Marc a quitté la France pour le Grand
Nord Philippe est propriétaire de ce
restaurant au bord de l'autoroute un
drôle d'endroit pour cultiver des
citrons manger bio et prendre le thé en
terrasse ici pas de stress l'ambiance
veut détendue surtout entre direction et
employ les relations sont beaucoup plus
ouvertes que j'ai vécu en France il n'y
a pas deouvement si s'il y a un problème
je veux dire c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'en parler de trouver quel problème il
n'y a pas un peu cette angoisse
hiérarchique que j'ai connu en France
elle est beaucoup moins présente dans la
relation patron employé au Danemark un
dialogue social apaisé qui a permis
d'instaurer la fameuse Flexi sécurité
pour les employés il est très facile de
trouver un emploi comme il est très
simple de licencer quand on est patron
is des anné le T de chmage reste sous la
Bar des 5% et les jeunes comme Mar
profitent pleinement de ce
[Musique]
système il suffit d'appeler une
entreprise ou un
restaurant ils sont souvent à la
recherche de
personnel oui c'est plutôt facile de
trouver un boulot au
danemar
et quand l'État providence at ses
limites la solidarité entre danois pr le
relais la femme de Philipp prêtre chaque
jour à l'hôpital elle rend visite à des
patients les Danois apprécient que
l'Église participe au bien-être commun
et la société se reconna dans certaines
de nos valeurs
au Danemark la religion protestante
imprène les mentalités et qu'on soit
pratiquant ou non l'entraide reste une
valeur
S c'est fantastique d'avoir quelqu'un
pour discuter de tout ce que j'ai en
tête
nous écoute pas comme un
prêtre mais comme un proche tout
[Musique]
simplement faement exportable avec
seulement 5,5 millions d'habitants le
pays peut facilement venir en aide à
tout le monde alors pour préserver cela
le Danemark a tendance à se refermer sur
lui-même la preuve il applique
aujourd'hui les lois migratoires les
plus strictes
[Musique]
d'Europe voilà on quitte le supposé pays
du bonheur pour rejoindre Bruxelles où
il fait beau aujourd'hui nous sommes
toujours au cœur du Parlement européen
avec deux invités de deux femmes deux
eurodéputés françaises Pascal Gruny
représentante du groupe des
conservateurs et chrétiensdémocrates le
PPE membre de la commission emploi
affaires sociales et vous êtes aussi
membre de la commission des pétitions
qui recueille les doléances des citoyens
en face de vous Nathalie grisbeck
bonjour député du MoDem vous siégez ici
au sein de l'Alliance des démocrates et
des libéux Européens alors une réaction
à ce reportage qui vous avez fait
beaucoup comment expliquez-vous tout
simplement qu'on puisse être plus
heureux au Danemark qu'ailleurs en
Europe je ne sais pas moi je pense que
ce reportage on aurait pu le faire aussi
avec une famille française moi ce que
j'ai constaté en fait dans le reportage
c'est quand même déjà le le niveau
social des des personnes interrogées
donc je crois savoir que qu'au Danemark
effectivement le niveau des emplois est
plus qualifié en fait que dans les
autres pays européens et ils ont plus de
difficultés finalement à trouver des des
employés pour les les postes les les
plus bas en niveau on n pas choisi le
Danemark par hasard ça ça repose sur des
études sérieuses qui établissent un
certain nombre de critères donc une une
qualité de la sécurité de l'emploi une
qualité de de protection sociale aussi
des infrastructures de de de transport
donc c'est c'est un petit peu plus large
aussi quand même ou oui oui oui ben le
bonheur c'est beaucoup de critères en
fait c'est c'est très personnel mais
c'est vrai que je pense que l'emploi il
contribue sérieusement donc actuellement
avec cette période de crise et et où il
y a beaucoup de de chômage en Europe
forcément ça ça joue sur le moral de nos
concitoyens ça c'est c'est certain
Nathalie grisbeck est-ce que ce modèle
danois qu'on a dont on a vu là une
partie vous vous fait rêver et
pensez-vous qu'il devrait s'exporter
ailleurs en Europe moi je pense que ce
qui se dégage enfin ce que
personnellement j'ai j'ai ressenti en en
suivant ce ce reportage très bien fait
ce qui se dégage c'est une espèce de
d'équilibre l'équilibre le jeune qui
donc apprend la responsabilité à l'école
tout en y allant à vélo dans des
conditions de sécurité l'équilibre et
l'harmonie de de la famille la diversité
aussi de leur centre d'intérêt la femme
qui est pasteur protestante et qui une
spiritualité c'est l'équilibre alors
pour moi le bonheur je rejoins ce qu'a
dit ma collègue vient cet équilibre
justement par c'est très difficile à
définir je pense que c'est quelque chose
c'est une espèce de quête perpétuelle
individuellement moi je ne saurais pas
définir exactement le bonheur alors le
bonheur ensuite pour une société c'est
un bonheur créer les conditions de la
vie en collectivité et au premier en
desqual il faut l'emploi et donc nous en
tant que femme engagée en en tant que
femme politique on on voit bien qu'il
faut tout faire de manière sans doute
communautaire pour créer de bonnes
conditions pour l'attractif l' et dans
notre pays la France c'est quelque chose
qui est difficile il y a c'est une
société beaucoup plus fracturée où il y
a pas c'est pas parce qu'on cherche un
emploi qu'on en trouve immédiatement
c'est pas parce qu'on veut dialoguer
avec son patron qu'on qu'on y parvient
c'est pas parce qu'on veut suivre une
formation qu'on y parvient
nécessairement donc c'est un équilibre à
trouver le modèle communautaire peut y
parvenir peut-être en temps de crise la
sécurité de l'emploi c'est un critère
numéro 1 une garantie nécessaire au
bien-être des des citoyens vous qui
connaissez bien cette question vous êtes
rapporteur ici au Parlement européen sur
le la flexibilité oui alors la sécurité
de l'emploi bien sûr c'est un critère
très important pour l'ensemble des des
des citoyens européens et français bien
entendu simplement c'est pas forcément
évident à trouver et et en fait on parle
la flexibilité c'est toujours bon les
entreprises elles disent nous il faut
absolument que vous nous donniez les
moyens effectivement de pouvoir
recruter quand on a des besoins et par
contre quand on en a moins il faudrait
qu'on puisse se séparer plus facilement
en fait de nos collaborateurs mais nous
il faut absolument aussi qu'on assure la
sécurité pour les salariés c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de Flex sécurité
c'est-à-dire que à la fois donner cette
flexibilité aux entreprises mais à la
fois assurer aux personnes qui vont
accepter ces contrats qui sont
finalement autre que typique atypique
bien entendu donc contrat à durée
déterminé intérime et C faut qu'on
assure derrière une protection sociale
en fait pour pour les salariés alors au
Danemark le cadre de vie et les
habitudes de consommation semble jouer
un un rôle important puisque les
Danois une grande majorité de danois
disent avoir une alimentation saine
équilibré c'est ce que nous explique
justement ce paère de famille qu'on a vu
dans le reportage
écoutez-le les gens qui viennent ici
àcheter du bio c'est sont des gens qui
sont
conscient bon des problèmes un peu
planétaires je veux dire ce qui se passe
sur le milieu ce qui se passe
socialement dans les pays non
sousdéveloppés dans les conditions de
travail sur les sur les gens qui
produisent ces produits et donc
lorsqu'ils achètent un produit bio ou un
produit fair trade bon ils ont
l'impression de participer sur une
amélioration des conditions de vie des
conditions amélioration climatique et
cetera je veux dire c'est un peu un
geste de d'être
avec alors vous pensez Nathalie
grriisbeck que le fait d'avoir des des
modes de consommation respectueux de de
l'environnement favorise le bien-être je
pense que ça peut y contribuer mais ce
qui est important c'est la liberté
qu'ils ont et qu'on associe très
fortement à la responsabilité cette
espèce de de prise de conscience
individuelle qu'on s'inscrit dans un
dans une lignée de génération modè auss
c'est un pays n oui ils ont pas la même
ils sont peut-être moins épicuriens
beaucoup plus justement influencé par la
religion protestante beaucoup plus
rigide et beaucoup plus plus attaché à
la responsabilité à la liberté
collective mais c'est un modèle
intéressant moi je pense à la phrase de
Saint- juste qui au moment de la
Révolution disait le bonheur une idée
neuve en Europe en fait bon on voit bien
dans nos sociétés puisquon est des femme
de terrain que on est loin des
conditions du bonheur pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens c'est pour ça en même
temp c'est aussi utopique de de vouloir
bah c'est une espèce de quête c'est un
objectif collectif qui en tous les cas
moi me man'anime et même si c'est
parfois un peu comme cisif on le voit
dans nos commissions moi en liberté on
voit bien que alors même qu'on pourrait
imaginer que l'Europe est un espace de
liberté de de paix sans doute mais de
liberté concrétisé il reste beaucoup à
faire on a créé il y a quelques jours là
un groupe de pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme c'est dire combien les
vieux démons du 20e siècle qui avaient
caractérisé le 20e siècle reviennent
donc faut tout le temps tout le temps
mettre l'ouvrage sur le métier et c'est
créer les conditions de bonheur c'est
pas facile est-ce que vous pensez
justement Pascal gruni que que l'État
l'État providence notamment qui semble
revenir un peu en à la faveur de la
crise peut garantir un certain nombre de
de conditions du bien-être de ces
citoyens est-ce que c'est c'est son rôle
a-t-il raison de se mêler de de bonheur
alors je sais pas si se mêle de bonheur
mais il doit contribuer effectivement à
ce que à ce que les ses citoyens puisse
se sentir bien dans dans leur pays donc
forcément c'est l'accompagnement à
l'emploi c'est une
éducation pour les enfants qui soient de
de bon niveau donc tout ça je pense que
ça fait partie effectivement des
mais il faut laisser la liberté aussi au
aux personnes c'est un choix il y a des
gens qui ont choisi de ne pas faire
d'études qui qui font des choix de de
partir vivre je ne sais pas au centre de
la France avec des des chèvres voilà
c'est et cette liberté est importante je
pense aussi dans dans dans la quête du
du bonheur une recette pas facile à
trouver merci beaucoup mesdames d'avoir
été sur ce plateau et on va se quitter
comme de coutume avec notre séquence
culturelle
le 13e festival du film court qui se
tient à Bruxelles et dans quatre villes
de walloni alors 223 films sont en
compétition venus de 40 pays différents
je vous invite à aller voir ce festival
c'est jusqu'au 9 mai on regarde la
[Musique]
bandeannonce
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
d'Europe Hebdo présenté depuis Bruxelles
on se retrouve comme d'habitude la
semaine prochaine bonne suite de
programme sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaires
I